what was the decision-making process
like
when the opportunity to do two big
things at fairly the same time godzilla
and the mcu
came up was that something you were
always open to or was there any
hesitation to commit
well it was a it was actually a funny um
like decision i had like put out in the
world and i talked to my
agent my manager and i you know nice who
are like my
other mothers like i just love them so
much um and i told them
i i want to be considered for the
projects that i grew up like
you know as a kid looking at star wars
and i was obsessed with star wars you
couldn't peel me away from star wars as
a child
um and so i was
you know trying to figure out like how
do i how do i how do i
start putting that out there because i
feel like all i'm getting are these like
really disturbed women in independent
films
and um it's like just a disturbed woman
and a
big franchise but um uh
they said take meetings and so with
these with people who run these
companies and so i
literally did um and i met with
kevin and a couple other people that had
that were working there at the time and
then um
and then i met with um
with the people who were running
legendary at the time and there are a
few others in
different places and the funny thing is
in the legendary meeting they said you
know directors cast films we don't cast
films we're creating an incubator for
directors to do what they want to do
and i was like totally fair so i just
kind of got lucky that
gareth cast me in godzilla when he
showed me this teaser of what he was
gonna do which they showed at
a comic-con um it was such beautiful
film-making
and you know you throw brian cranston
and julia promotion and you're like oh
sign me up
um so that so that was that was how that
one happened
luckily gareth came from you know
independent cinema as
well and so i think that's how that
worked out for me and then um
uh joss had aaron and i in mind for
quicksilver and ph for and scarlet witch
and so
he and i both took separate meetings
aaron and i
both took several meetings with joss
while we were doing reshoots for
godzilla
and aaron and i kind of were like should
we are we both gonna do this like this
is so funny like should we
you know move on from being a husband
and wife and being brother and sister
and so it all it all happened very close
to the time of me taking those meetings
and i think what happens is you just get
in the forefront of people's heads
um when you take those meetings and
whatever the discussions are that
happens
and that's what happened with catherine
han with kevin feige for one division
she went on a general
and um very quickly
around the same time they're prepping
one division and she
was like the first person that came up
and they wanted to cast agnes and so
it is there is something to it about
taking these
generals that um you know feel so
awkward
usually because it always just feels
like you know you're
you're marketing yourself which is what
you're kind of doing you're also just
trying to have a conversation about what
they're doing as well or what they're
interested in
putting out in the world yeah sounds
sounds like a necessary
step to take it's the it seems like the
only possible route to really understand
what everybody else is doing around you
that could be an option to you
yeah i mean i i felt that way and i
you know i wasn't like i was a comic
book person
it was just that i loved iron man
i really loved iron man and i remember
hearing
my brother talk about oh is this are you
meeting on guardians like
he already knew about all these things
that were happening that i didn't
he was really telling me how exciting
the next chapter of
marvel was going to be and so it made me
the way he talked about it made me
excited
and you know he's not the industry he's
just a fan
you